ils sont encore loin des champs de
bataille mais les Ukrainiens ont enfin
mis la main sur le volant des chars
léopards 2
pour des raisons de sécurité nous ne
pouvons vous montrer leur visage mais
ils sont une centaine de soldats
fraîchement arrivés des lignes de front
à l'est de l'Ukraine
major nous soldats aiment vraiment
facile à conduire il assure un bon
niveau de protection et un très bon
moteur
[Applaudissements]
de soldats canadiens qui viennent tout
juste d'être déployés en Pologne pour
former les campus ukrainiens
ici elle conduit une simulation
d'attaque pour illustrer ce que l'on
attend deux des communications claires
des gestes rapides et synchronisés une
concentration totale
la grande majorité des soldats en
formation sont des tankistes
d'expériences maintenant après un an de
guerre aux commandes de vieux chars de
type soviétique il s'ajusteront
rapidement à leur nouvelle équipements
assurent leurs commandes
sont qualifiés dit-il ils ont
l'expérience de nos chars à leurs
entraînement sur ses chars là et plus
facile ce sont des tanquises c'est comme
de conduire une Mercedes et de passer à
une Volkswagen
pour leur permettre de retourner au
combat le plus vite possible la
formation a été condensée dans le temps
au maximum fait valoir le commandant
adjoint du centre d'entraînement des
Polonais qui nous a demandé de ne pas
publier son nom
en Pologne l'inquiétude et profonde ici
on redoute sérieusement que les
ambitions territoriales devraient
au-delà des frontières de l'Ukraine
voisine la Pologne a militait sans
réserve pour la livraison de Charles
léopard à l'Ukraine
les chars léopard offrent aux Ukrainiens
un avantage stratégique qu'il réclamait
depuis les tout début de la guerre mais
il ne faut pas croire prévient-on ici
que ça va changer la situation sur le
terrain du jour au lendemain
formation accélérée ou pas les tankistes
ukrainien n'en sont pas encore à pouvoir
tester les tirs de leur futur engins de
guerre pour le moment c'est sur ces
simulateurs qu'ils doivent acquérir de
l'expérience sous le regard avisé de
leurs instructeurs Canadiens ils
apprennent à piloter débusquer l'ennemi
et tirer avec précision
le majeur rodaq ne ménage pas son
enthousiasme et sa reconnaissance envers
ses alliés mais son jugement final du
léopard 2 il le réserve pour plus tard
c'est trop tôt pour parler de
supériorité sur notre ennemi il faut
pouvoir se servir de la technologie au
combat dit-il sur la ligne de front
quand nous verrons les résultats nous en
tirons des conclusions
il se rend de retour au front dans
quelques semaines à peine une unité de
temps kyste transformée il rejoindront
une armée ukrainienne qui tranquillement
devient compatible avec les forces de
l'OTAN
pour l'Ukraine c'est peut-être en soi
une victoire importante